with joe biden flailing you would
imagine that republicans would just let
him flail would you not that of course
would be the smart move
however you can always count on
republicans to be as stupid as humanly
possible at least a small percentage of
them
because
late on friday the house of
representatives passed a roughly 1
trillion publix works bill sending to
president biden's desk a generational
investment in roads bridges and rail
that had languished for several months
as democrats feuded over the terms of
its approval now you'll remember that
this thing has already passed the senate
and that mitt romney had voted for it
and that susan collins had voted for it
and rob portman and ohio had voted for
it and then joe biden didn't want the
house to only vote on it right joe biden
wanted to tie that together with bill
back better the idea being that if
mansion and cinema wanted their
bipartisan bipartisan infrastructure
plan passed they would also have to vote
in favor of build back better then it
turned out that mansion and cinema
weren't going to budge and then biden
was stuck in a pickle because the
progressives said we will not vote for
bipartisan infrastructure unless we get
a vote from manchin and cinema and build
back better right carmilla jayapal had
led that way as well
well late last week carmilla tried pulp
basically caved on it
pramila jayapal was like okay fine you
know what we know that we're not going
to be able to hold up the bipartisan
infrastructure plan to get mansion in
cinema cave so we do want that
bipartisan infrastructure plan passed we
will vote in favor of it with like a
basic proviso that maybe will get a vote
on buildback better sometime down the
road
and so on friday a statement came out
from the moderate wing of the democratic
party saying they will commit to voting
for the build back better act in its
current form other than technical
changes they still want the cost from
the cbo by the week of november 15th
they say they will resolve any
discrepancies that come up in the
interim to get it passed but that
doesn't matter because again mansion and
cinema are the ones who actually matter
in this particular conversation but then
pramila jayapal put out a statement
saying quote tonight members of the
progressive caucus and our colleagues in
the democratic caucus reached an
agreement to advance both pieces of
president biden's legislative agenda our
colleagues have committed to voting for
the transformative buildback better act
as currently written no later than the
week of november 15th all of our
colleagues have also committed to voting
tonight on the rule to move the build
back better act forward to codify this
promise the president has affirmed these
members gave him the same commitment
okay but there was one problem left
because he had the progressives and the
moderates saying we'll vote for some
rule to ex to push forward bill back
better even though we know it's probably
going to die a horrible painful death in
the senate
and we'll vote in favor of bipartisan
infrastructure there's one problem you
still had six outstanding democrats
namely the squad and their adjunct
members who were voting against
bipartisan infrastructure democrats
could only afford to lose three votes
and still pass bipartisan infrastructure
in the house
right so they've lost six which means
they didn't have the votes for either
build back better or for the bipartisan
infrastructure act because they lacked
the votes for bipartisan infrastructure
in the house and they didn't have the
votes for buildback better in the senate
so this is the point where if you're a
republican you stand there and you let
them flail you just let them flail right
because why would you hand them a win
well the answer is because republicans
at least 13 of them are just complete
morons
and or they are so eager to slap their
own party in the face that they voted
against the rest of their republican
colleagues in order to vote for this
infrastructure plan which again is a
giant boondoggle it is 1.2 trillion
dollars of spending that are unnecessary
the vast majority of infrastructure
spending that needs to be done is
supposed to be done at the state level
the notion that america's infrastructure
is completely failing all of our bridges
and roads are falling apart it's not
true
in my most non-partisan studies the
united states infrastructure is in the
main okay
and if you want to upgrade it that is
something that can be done at the state
level there's no reason why florida
should be paying for new york's
infrastructure problems
okay but nonetheless you had 13
republicans who then voted in favor of
the bipartisan infrastructure bill and
handed the flailing joe biden a falling
apart show biden a win
which is just garbage it's just garbage
it's senator bill hagerty of tennessee
he says yeah there's no question the
republicans bailed nancy pelosi out
right here
how do you feel as a republican about
those 13 who voted for this
well neil you recall that i fought this
very hard in the senate
it was very surprising to me to see 13
republicans basically bail nancy pelosi
out she did not have the votes within
her own party to do this we had 13
republicans that decided to step up and
help her in this way i think what they
did was put themselves on a path to
early retirement
and that is correct
every person on the republican side of
the aisle who voted in favor of the
infrastructure plan should get primary
to every single one of these people
and they include some moderates you know
people like jeff andrew who used to be a
democrat
by the way there how many members of how
many republican members from new york
alone voted for this thing one two
let's see one two three
four
there are four from new york who voted
for this plus another two from new
jersey so basically it's new york and
new jersey that voted in favor of this
thing
right new york and new jersey voted in
favor of this thing and everybody else
is like no we're not doing it
he had a couple of others he had done
young from alaska you had fred upton
from michigan but every single member
who voted for this thing on the right
side of the aisle should be primary you
don't get to vote for joe biden's
signature pieces of legislation at a
time when we've already blown out the
spending and when inflation is setting
in
and when we already have a debt to gdp
ratio higher than at any time since
world war ii
and then get to survive a primary
challenge that is not something that
should happen inside the republican
party it's a disgrace
according to the wall street journal a
major piece of mr biden's economic
agenda and his vision for making the us
more competitive internationally its
passage in the house hands him a
bipartisan achievement that presidents
of both parties have tried and failed to
achieve for years again remember he had
to do this with republican votes he
could not accomplish it with just
democratic votes so this is republican's
fault
i don't know what house speaker mccarthy
had to do to make sure that those 13
republicans didn't go along with joe
biden here or if there was anything he
could have done but bottom line is if
you cannot whip your party hard enough
to ensure that they don't vote for the
other guy on a bill that has no interior
support inside the republican party i
don't know what you are doing
his sagging poll numbers and democrats
recent loss in the gubernatorial race in
virginia had pushed democrats to muscle
the legislation through the finish line
this week but the effort was circuitous
and tortured for house democrats whose
paper thin majority repeatedly
complicated leadership's plan for the
legislation democrats had started friday
planning to approve the infrastructure
bill after passing the rest of the
party's priorities in a separate roughly
2 trillion education healthcare and
climate package
regressive democrats demanded the social
spending legislation first received a
vote in the house hoping to ensure that
centrist would support it that design
then fell apart because centrist
democrats said they needed more time to
analyze the cost of the social spending
bill so then pelosi just brought up the
infrastructure bill and she didn't have
the votes she brought up for a vote and
she didn't have the votes these 13
republicans bailed out nancy pelosi
they bailed him they bailed her out
it's unbelievable
and what exactly is the rationale for
this
seriously where is the deep-seated
republican need to pass this thing
it's just it's just garbage and
stupidity and a lot of it is spiked by
some of these members you'll notice a
lot of names that voted for trump's
impeachment who are on that same list
right there i don't think that that's a
coincidence
what a disaster area this of course
allowed joe biden to go out there and
mock trump and try to take a triumphant
lap now
the triumph is not going to last for
very long
it really is not because the truth is
the infrastructure bill is going to help
virtually no one and no one thinks it's
going to help them so it's just going to
look like a big bag of spending it's
going to allow him to say that he did an
uh bipartisan thing which is the only
bipartisan thing that has happened
throughout his entire administration
again i thought this is a bad move from
the time that republicans agreed to it
and i think that in the senate the math
for mitt romney and susan collins and
company was probably that if they got
mansion and cinema on board with
bipartisan infrastructure that this
would also get them to stand up against
buildback better so it's one or the
other in the senate but in the house it
wasn't in the house the house
republicans could just say no and that
would have been the end of it then it
would have been toast it would have been
done
instead they handed biden to victory and
he got out he got to go out there and uh
and triumphally make his uh appeal to
the american people
infrastructure week
[Laughter]
i'm so happy to say that infrastructure
week
he's making fun of trump of course
because every week in trump's
administration was infrastructure week
and infrastructure never really got done
and of course he had to break it's
hilarious how they've been stashing
kamala harris away and only when they do
something that is camera friendly do
they sort of trot her out and then they
just shove her right back wherever she
came from it's okay you need to go back
into that closet there and stay there
commonwealth until next time when we try
you out and pretend that you had
something to do with with any of this
according to cnn both biden and his
cabinet officials are now going to go on
an infrastructure tour which is what
americans are up for i mean there's
nothing that sounds like as much fun as
an infrastructure tour and it sounds
like you know just a great band or
something it's gonna be awesome
today the president touted the bill at
the white house and
cnn has now learned that biden and his
top cabinet officials plan to hit the
road and tour the country in the coming
weeks to promote the benefits of this
bill oh how exciting they're going to
run around the country talking about how
much of your money they're now spending
by the way what exactly is in the bill
it includes 110 billion dollars in
funding for roads bridges and major
projects as well as 39 billion dollars
to modernize and make public transit
more accessible to the disabled and the
elderly most of that is going to go to
new york and a huge chunk of that is
going to go to new york city so i'm glad
that you get to pay for new york subway
system that's exciting stuff also you
will notice that the price tag on this
bipartisan infrastructure bill is
something like 1.2 trillion and yet the
bill is 110 billion for roads bridges
and other major projects when most
people think of infrastructure that is
what they think of right
that is not where most of the bill's
money goes the deal includes a 66
billion investment in rail maintenance
most of which will go to amtrak
amtrak so joe biden finally got to bail
out his favorite train because that dude
loves amtrak and tells all sorts of lies
about all the people he's met on amtrak
and he he he treats his travel on amtrak
as some sort of actual presidential
credential
the legislation will provide 11 billion
dollars in funding for highway and
pedestrian safety programs i know what
that means what is a pedestrian safety
program telling people not to walk on
freeways or what a total of 7.5 billion
will go to implementing a network of
electric vehicle chargers because again
it is not as though private companies
have an incentive to ensure that there
are evs
charging at their stations right we
actually need to have the state do it
because if the state doesn't do it then
probably nobody will build it except for
how there are ev chargers at pretty much
every gas station now but aside from
that another 7.5 billion will be used
for zero emission or low emission buses
and ferries ports and airports will be
boosted with 42 billion dollars in new
spending
also they're going to put 65 billion
dollars toward broadband infrastructure
and development
it'll include 73 billion to update and
expand the power grid
how exactly are they going to pay for
all of this well
they're going to have 200 billion
dollars in repurposed funds originally
intended for coronavirus relief but left
unused
so they're just taking all the money
they're supposed to spend for covert
relief and they're going to dump it on
this
about 50 billion will come from delaying
a trump era rule on medicare rebates
50 billion from certain states returning
unused unemployment insurance
supplemental funds
also senators say they expect 30 billion
to be generated from applying
information reporting requirements for
cryptos they're going to tax crypto
essentially nearly 60 billion will come
from the economic growth spurred by the
spending yeah sure
yeah i'm sure because so much economic
growth is going to get spurred by
wasting this amount of money
the uh nonpartisan scorekeeper found the
infrastructure bill would widen the
federal budget deficit by about 256
billion dollars over 10 years so no it's
not going to be covered
how about human infrastructure
well they're still going to be pushing
that in buildback better so very
exciting stuff
okay so again republicans hand biden an
imagistic victory here for no apparent
reason
and there should be blowback on all 13
members of the house who decided to vote
in favor of the again a giant spending
monstrosity that was unnecessary in the
first place and that allows joe biden a
victory lap at a time when his
presidency is in the state of complete
collapse political malpractice in the
extreme
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video